foreign
[Music]
and welcome to the second part of uh our
pawn and game practicum in which I give
you 10 challenging exercises to test
your understanding of the ideas and
Concepts that I outlined in the five
instructional Pawn end game videos and
then carefully present the Solutions in
this and the previous video so a lot of
you might notice that this is indeed a
re-recording uh of this very same video
which I initially put out uh two days
ago upon which I realized that it
sounded like a video from the early
2000s the audio quality was terrible and
because you know I put a lot of effort
into preparing these videos I want the
final product to be as pleasant to
listen to as possible I just want to say
how much I appreciate people's
understanding everybody was super kind
but uh there's nothing wrong with
expecting a a solid final product
there's a lot of things you could be
doing and watching you could be watching
House of dragon or peaky blinders or
Sunday Night Football and I I greatly
appreciate that you decide to watch
these videos they're long they can be
hard to listen to and you know my brand
is to strive for perfection in every
video so it really is not a problem to
be to be re-recording this I moved into
a different room with less Echo I
positioned my mic a lot closer to me and
uh even though I don't think this is
going to be quite as good as when I
record from my home in Charlotte
hopefully the audio quality is going to
be better I'm keeping my fingers crossed
uh and and once again you know I greatly
appreciate this community I know that
people wouldn't have a problem if I left
the initial recording up but uh I'm also
taking this opportunity I think to make
the final product better uh and to
actually improve the quality of the
analysis as well so without further Ado
let us jump in I'm gonna switch scenes
here and I remind you that in the
description to this video you will find
two links the first is to the puzzles
it's a link to a leeches study and the
second uh link is to the fully worked
out and written out Solutions uh and the
way I recommend to watch this video is
to first attempt the problems yourself
you can make moves directly on the
leeches study or you can download them
and solve them in whichever PGN viewer
you prefer then I recommend that you
watch this video carefully and then you
can review the written out Solutions at
your leisure and analyze with an engine
if that's what you prefer but if you
just want to view this as a regular
instructional video if you don't really
want to do the puzzles on your own
that's also totally fine and I think you
can extract a lot of instructional value
just from uh watching watching me
present the solutions uh and I will
still try to work in a couple of puzzles
in the video itself I'll tell you to
pause at various points so whichever way
you want to do this is totally
acceptable and uh the last thing I'll
remind you of is that the puzzles are
indeed very challenging so don't feel
like if you don't get five out of five
correct that you somehow haven't paid
attention to the instructional videos
these are meant not only to help you
repeat and sort of uh rehearse the
concepts that I presented but also to
help you deepen your understanding of
them uh so so there's going to be some
new Concepts that are are talked about
in these in these puzzles as well
so let's jump into the actual Solutions
our first puzzle comes from a game
between two strong Grand Masters a Dutch
GM John Vander wheel and uh Filipino
Legend legendary Grandmaster Eugenio
Torre played Black and in this position
it is white to move so as a diligent
student of Pawn end games the first
thing you should notice is is really the
positioning of the Kings the kings are
locked in a life or death battle for
territory in the center and the proper
terminology to describe this is mutual
zugsvang which is a situation in which
both sides want the other side to be the
one to move their King and if that
happens then uh one of the sides loses
their crucial Pawn if black has to move
his King he loses D4 uh if white moves
his King he loses E4 in both cases the
other side has a deadly extra passed
Pawn so another way to put this is that
the kings are occupying corresponding
squares which are squares of mutual so
normally when that happens uh the battle
transitions to waiting moves both sides
start to exhaust their waiting moves and
the side that exhausts their waiting
moves last induces zuke's Wong forces
the opponent to move their King and wins
the game uh all of that sounds simple
and it might therefore seem that white
should just push a random pod and start
exhausting his waiting moves but that
doesn't tell the whole story if you look
carefully you will notice that black
actually has a deadly threat if white
just makes a random waiting move such as
A6 black is going to respond to the move
C6 to C5 defending his pass Pawn on D4
and taking waiting moves largely out of
the equation with a pawn protected black
and now move is King to F4 but in
addition to that white will exhaust his
waiting moves first so you simply cannot
allow black to play C5 for example let's
say white plays B3 uh black and play G5
G4 H6 and clear clearly white is the one
who has to who has to move his King and
lose the E4 Pawn so the first move can
be arrived at largely without too much
calculation you have to play the move B2
to B4 to isolate the D4 upon and prevent
black from pushing C5 now the the
waiting game begins in Earnest black
responds with the move A6 exhausting his
only waiting move on the queen side and
now the battle transitions to the king
side
now White's next move can be arrived at
by process of elimination right you have
to be very very careful about how you
push these King side pawns and it turns
out that pushing your Jeep on loses the
game immediately G4 is the worst move in
the position because it allows black to
Deep Freeze White's pawns with G5 why
does no more moves and white is in
zugsbon G3 is a little bit more
resilient but here black can win with H6
creating a very nasty scenario in which
whichever Pawn white pushes on the king
side black simply pushes the same pawn
and induces zoosong H4 H5 or G4 G5 we
already talked about the scenario in
both cases white is in zuk zwang so the
only logical move is actually to push
your h-bawn leaving yourself with a
maximum amount of waiting moves with the
g-pod now if black responds with H5 then
everything is very simple we play G3 and
now it is black who is in zugzong and
has to move his King back
of course black should instead play H6
following the rule that you should never
exhaust uh more than one waiting move
when possible so black plays H6 and now
White's best move is G2 G4 creating the
same exact scenario where you know black
pushes upon we push the opposite Pawn
forward freezing the king side pawns and
inducing Zog zwang so now it might seem
like the game is simply over black plays
G5 white plays H5 and black has to move
as king and kudos to you if you were
able to reach this position in your
calculations but if you force yourself
to carry on you might notice that the
game is far from over because yes black
is technically in zogzong but that in
itself doesn't always mean uh that the
side witches in zulilan can resign and
if you calculate further you will see
black has this move King F4 black can go
after the G4 pawn and after King takes
D4 King takes G4 white hits a major
problem if white plays E5 black doubles
back to F5 stopping the E Pawn but most
importantly the move King D5 which would
assist the further progress of the epon
is now not possible so it may seem
patently obvious that black is now just
winning black is just going to start
pushing his Jeep on the pathway is clear
and if white dips back with his King he
loses the E5 pawn and this is where
white has an absolutely brilliant
resource now the first thing which may
come to mind is The Logical move King C5
maybe you can try to create a past spawn
on the queen side and this is indeed a
way to save the game after King takes E5
King takes C6 we get into a pawn race G4
B5 this is an easy breakthrough black
plays a takes B5
white pushes A6 and you will notice that
the pawns promote simultaneously white
promotes versus black promotes next and
this is just a dead draw I can win the
H6 spawn or White can take the B5 Pawn
but there are no uh skewers available so
the game ends in a draw but if we rewind
to the critical position after E5 King
F5 white actually has a winning move and
major kudos to you if you were able to
find the brilliant Pawn breakthrough B4
B5 putting the pawn on pre two different
ways now the moment this move is played
its intention should become immediately
clear to you and I will say that it is
also possible just the same exact thing
it's possible to play the move on the
previous move but I think for greater
effect we will start with E5 and follow
up with B5 if black plays a takes B5
then everything is simple this is just a
traditional Pawn breakthrough white
promotes the a pawn but if black plays C
takes B5
the secondary Point becomes clear you
have paved the way for whites King to
reach this crucial D5 Square allowing
the further progress of White's past
epon and I think this really calls forth
the concept that breakthroughs aren't
only carried out in order to create past
pawns that's the main reason but in the
previous video on advanced concepts we
talked about alternate uses of Pawn
breakthroughs you can also break through
or sacrifice your Pawns in order to
generate important squares for your king
or in order to favorably modify the pawn
structure in some other way so so
remember to think of Pawn Breakers a
little bit more broadly right you can
sacrifice four squares you can sacrifice
for past bonds you can sacrifice to
change the pawn structure and and this
is a great application of that but still
the game is not over because you might
notice that if black pushes either the b
or the G Pawn the pawns actually promote
simultaneously so let's consider both of
these options if I plays B4 y pushes E6
and this is what I really love about
this example I can promote either one of
two pawns and in both cases white has a
little sequence to win Black's newly
minted Queen here it's all very simple
E7 B2 E8 B1 and you should notice that
the king and the queen are aligned
diagonally in the pawn race video I
advised you to never stop calculating
just because the pawns promote
simultaneously you can't just assume
that the game ends in a draw you have to
keep calculating and mainly you have to
check whether you can win your
opponent's Queen with a skewer and here
you can do just that with Queen G6 check
and you pick up the queen on B1 now I
will add that if black tries to stop the
progress of white spawn with King F6
then we advance our King to D6 we've
talked about this scenario at length in
the pawn race video and here you might
say well black and now promote the B
Pawn and there's no more skewer on G6
but now there's a Checkmate on f8 just
look at this mating construction the H5
Pawn is the unsung hero of this entire
procedure because it guards the G6
square or it anchors that square for a
White's Queen
I would say okay well no problem I get
it what if black pushes his other Bond
what if black pushes the Jeep on well
here you should already recognize a
certain scenario unfolding after E6 G3
E7 G2 e8g1 again the pawns promote
simultaneously but again we see the king
and the Queen on adjacent files which is
often a precursor to a skewer as it is
in fact here uh the kings are in
opposition which is very important black
speaking has no access to squares on the
Eve plus let me just give a Chuck on F7
push the king to the G file and skewer
the king in one of three ways picking up
Black's new Queen and winning the game
so black has one could say three
separate ways uh to carry on in this
position after E5 B5 and King D5 black
can promote the peep on the g-pawn or
black and try to advance the king back
to F6 and stop the progress of white
sweep on but all three of these ways get
punished in uh three separate ways two
skewers and in the case of King F6 black
actually gets checkmated on F6 so just a
brilliant illustration not only of of
waiting moves which is sort of first
part of this game but then of the
alternate uses of the pawn breakthrough
here white breaks through in order to
generate a key Square for his King so
hopefully you enjoyed this first puzzle
on we go to our next puzzle which comes
from a really old game between two very
weak players Emmanuel Lasker former
world champion and zebra tarash who was
one of the the defining figures of the
early 20th century he formulated a lot
of uh positional theory that we now take
for granted we very much stand on the
shoulders of giants uh when it comes to
our chess understanding uh and and you
know I look through a lot of Pawn end
games from the early 1900s and there
were a lot of mistakes you know upon End
Game Theory and end game theory in
general wasn't very well developed
principles weren't always a well
understood even by the leading players
but in this end game Tara Oscar really
comes through with a a clutch sequence
of moves to save the game now you might
hear me say that save the game and you
might say well that's kind of absurd
white is the one who's got the outside
passer here and we've been through this
before you might say well this is a
classic scenario in which white has to
use the H fund to distract Black's King
and then leisurely walk White's own King
to the queen side and just eliminate all
of Black's pawns we have plenty of Pawns
of Our Own in the queen side but you
know it's very important to look at this
position more concretely and to ask
yourself whether black actually has a
queen side threat and if you ask
yourself that you will notice that in
fact black does have a very nasty Queen
side threat if white plays a neutral
such as king F7 black is going to push
C4
I might say well after bcbc the B2 Pawn
is deep freezing Black's pawns but
that's very untrue in the pawn
Breakthrough video I talked about the
gap tooth Pawn formation where you have
pawns on uh on disjointed files Like A
and C or B and D and you push one of
them in order to create a passer on the
other side you push the C Pawn then the
a pawn becomes the passer or you push
the a pawn and the c bond becomes the
passer here of course the C Pawn is more
further Advanced so after something like
H4 black pushes C3 breakthrough BC A4
and black has an Unstoppable pass Pawn
on A4 and white is not fast enough if
white pushes the C Pawn black
unfortunately promotes first and stops
the C Pawn easily and if in this
position or uh yeah in this position
white plays H5 black steps to G5 and
stops the H1 with his King in both cases
white loses the game
so it's clear from this calculation that
white will have to use the H Pawn as a
decoy white has to distract Black's King
from F5 and why it has to make a b line
for his side of the board otherwise
there's no way you're going to have a
chance to stop black from queening his
one of his Queen side Pawns so the only
logical first move is in fact h2h4
now Black's response is forced white
threatens the move H5 so if black
doggedly carries on with C4 then after
bcbc H5 everything is very easy in fact
after C3 uh only white is the white is
the only one with winning chances A4 H6
we have simultaneous promotion and uh
White is an extra C Pawn so white can
try to play for a win here so of course
rewinding back to the position after
White's first move black will play King
F5 to G4 stopping White's H Pawn and
this leads us to the critical moment of
this example so it might seem once again
totally obvious that the correct move is
King F6 like I said we have to make a b
line for the queen side and this is the
mathematically fastest way to do that
but chess is not always a game that
abides by you know neat rules of
mathematics and if we calculate this on
you will notice that after C4 BC BC it
looks like white is about to stop
Black's pawns but we're one tempo short
C3 that breakthrough again bca4 and
amazingly after King D4 A3 White's very
own C3 pawn stops the king from stopping
the a pawn mathematically white is fast
enough but because you have this darned
Pawn on C3 black pawn still promotes and
this is a very common theme in a lot of
Pawn end game compositions or studies uh
and and here it prevents the white king
from stopping Black's Pawn so amazingly
the totally natural move King F6
actually loses the game we have to find
an alternate route but there seems to to
be no alternate route I mean f65 seems
to be the only way to access the queen
side
well in order to understand uh the
Brilliance of lasker's idea it is
helpful to look at another example this
is perhaps the most famous pawn end game
of all time I didn't really get around
to showing you this in one of the
instructional videos a lot of you will
immediately recognize this position it
is a composition it is a composed
position by rihard Reddy who was one of
the leading players of the 20th century
but he was also a an endgame
theoretician he developed a lot of
modern understanding
and most famously he composed this
incredibly paradoxical position and if
you see this if you're seeing this for
the first time you're really in for a
treat
so he composed this I think in the 1920s
it is white to move and White's goal is
to draw the game
now if you say this at a party you might
get laughed out of the building draw the
game black has an age Pawn that's a
thousand steps away from lights King
while widespawn is totally uh condemned
if you play C7 black easily stops the
pawn with King p7 but amazingly it turns
out that white can use the C Pawn as a
bargaining chip to gain the Tempe that
he needs to stop Black's H5 Pawn so to
stop this Pawn how many Tempe do we need
to gain well we need King G7 King F6 and
King E5 we need we need to gain three
Tempi so we start by playing the move
King G7 here's Tempo number one of
course black responds by pushing the
pawn H4
and there's the rub if white just goes
in a straight line black obviously just
promotes with H3 but white takes a
diagonal route we chart a chorus to F6
and there lies the rub if black stubborn
only pushes the pawn all of a sudden the
king doubles back toward the center King
E6 supporting the C pawn and allowing it
to promote simultaneously for example
King B6 we go King D7 h2c7 pawns promote
simultaneously and black does not have a
win Queen H3 check the king is able to
keep in contact with the queen this is a
draw
so you might say well no problem you
know black has a lot of Tempe to spare
so after King F6 we're just gonna go
King B6 and eliminate this Pawn
preemptively but now the white king
continues its diagonal route King to E5
and this actually is a double attack
white threatens to stop the pawn with
King F4 gaining that third Tempo white
also threatens to advance the king to D6
supporting the path of the C pawn and
there's nothing the black can do about
both threads of black xc6 then white
doubles back to F4 stopping the h-pawn
and if black plays H3 we've been through
this before white plays King D6 H2 C7
and all is well under the sun both pawns
promote simultaneously
amazingly this actually is a drawable
position white takes the diagonal route
using his past Pawn as a decoy uh to to
find the most efficient way to stop
black Sage bond this is the famous ready
study and you definitely should be uh
familiar with it if you are you know a
diligent student of the end game okay
so hopefully you're able to kind of see
the connection here you can do something
very very similar where you use this H4
Pawn as a decue rather than going King
F6 the only drawing move is actually
King to G6 King to G6 threatening to
play H5 much like in the ready study
forcing black to take on H4 and now you
have a more efficient Pathway to the
queen side you go King F5 and if you
compare this to the line where the white
king is on F6 after C4 BC BC here the
king moved back to E5 but now it can
move back to E4 and after C3 BC A4 the
king simply circumvents this obstacle on
C3 we play King D3 A3 King C2 and not
only does white stop the pawn here white
actually wins the game because white has
this additional C3 Pawn so incidentally
in order to draw already in this
position black is the one who's got to
be very careful I'm pretty sure the only
way to draw is to move move Black's King
to the G file but that's outside the
scope of the video
uh tarash obviously realized what was
going on and he immediately acquiesced
to the inevitable and he decided that
he's going to force a draw by playing
King G3 now White's King smoothly makes
its way to the queen side eliminating
all of Black's pawns one after the other
gobble gobble King T5 King E3 King takes
E5 and actually is black who has to be
accurate here King D2 King takes B5 and
black is the one who draws by the skin
of his teeth with King C2 King takes A5
and of course King takes B3 atarash
avoids the last trap taking this Pawn
would be a pretty bad idea indeed
because of B4 so uh again you know this
is not a one-to-one similarity with a
ready study but hopefully you're able to
see the conceptual similarity you go
rather than going King F6 which seems to
be the most efficient path you actually
use the H Pawn in order to generate a
more efficient path to the queen side
with this move King to G6
okay on we go to our next example
and this will just take me a second I
need to copy this into
um into into my chest.com study so just
a moment here
okay there we go
and back we go to the initial position
okay so this next example comes from
another game between two strong Grand
Masters the player who has the white
pieces needs no introduction this is
Victor corcinoy and on the black side is
a very strong Hungarian GM recently died
uh julas
and it is black to play in this position
so you should notice pretty early on
that there is a striking similarity to
our first exercise and our first
exercise uh if we rewind back to the
initial position we have this this
battle for territory in the king side in
the in the center in the situation of
mutual zooang and and here we have
something very similar if we flip the
board black can actually orchestrate the
same exact scenario by playing natural
move King to E5 this virtually forces
white to play King D3 and we have uh an
almost identical scenario to to our
first exercise where both sides start to
exhaust their waiting moves and and hope
to force the opponent to be the one to
move their King now in comparison to our
first example here black has an
abundance of waiting moves on the queen
side black has doubled apons which
hamstrings his ability to create a past
Pawn but does add an incredible amount
of waiting moves black can play the move
A3 and then has actually three waiting
moves with this other Apon that is a
massive asset in a situation like this
so it's worth starting with a move like
G5 in order to prevent white from
pushing F4 and dislodging Black's King
from the D4 Pawn but keep this idea in
mind it seems like black wins in
elementary fashion in fact this is what
sax played accordion I played F3 uh if
white plays G3 then it's even worse
Black just deep freezes white spawns
with G4 and this is immediate zugzvan
after like a3a5
so unfortunately plays F3 sax plays a
three freezing whites remaining Queen
Side Pawn G3 and of course A6 or A5
doesn't even matter sax played A5
um black as waiting moves to spare also
with the F Pawn and it seems like the
game is over white has to play G4 black
plays either F6 or A4 pushing the king
away from D3 and although black
cannot take on e4 directly black and
ahead for F4 and eliminate uh White's
remaining King side pawns winning the
game easily but here it's very important
not to forget a detail after A5 white is
not actually forced to play G4 and this
is what sex overlooked when he played
the move King E5 kudos to you if you
were able to see that white actually can
play the move f for check and this is
again why you shouldn't just calculate
waiting Moves In This mechanical fashion
you should remember that your opponent
can actually modify the bond structure
to his favor F4 dislodges whites King a
blacks King from the D4 pawn and forces
an immediate drop because after GF GF
King takes F4 King takes D4 you get a
situation in which white is not going to
lose control over the E4 pawn and if the
E4 Pawn is traded for the F Pawn then it
doesn't actually even matter if black is
the first one to get to the A2 Pawn
because black has Corner pawns which
means that as long as white ensures that
he can reach the C2 Square when black
takes on A2 that's a theoretical draw
that I've talked about in previous
videos and white draws in many different
ways here for example let's say black
plays F6 right trying to shoulder whites
King away from D4 opposition doesn't
matter here
white plays King D5 black plays King E3
again yes congratulations you've
shouldered White's King away from the E
Pawn but white draws in one of many ways
just King E6 is the simplest way King
takes E4 King takes F6
and now white pursues the black king
into the corner as we've done so many
times in these videos can be two King D3
King takes a two King C2 and of course
this is a well-known theoretical draw
doesn't matter how many a pawns are on
the board uh you might say oh but I can
play A4 and this is zuzuong but white
just drops back to C1 and then goes to
B1 and again doesn't matter how many
Corner pawns black has this is a a very
well known theoretical draw block has to
start giving away a Pawns in order to
avoid stalemate so let's rewind back to
um back to this position before we tried
F6 if black plays King F3 instead uh
it's it's also just a dead draw I can
play King E5 King E3 King F5
King D3 and now the simplest just to
push this Pawn to E5 threatening King F6
black can't really go to C3 black has to
go to D4 and now just King F6 then King
takes F7 and again uh y just pursues
Black's King into the corner doesn't
matter how you slice it this is just a
dead draw so amazingly the ridiculously
natural move King D6 to E5
relinquishes the win and this is why you
should be so careful about over trusting
your intuition in Pawn end games your
intuition will often suggest that you
should move the king into the most
natural square but the specifics of the
position will often dictate that another
course should be taken and this is a
great illustration of that the best move
the only winning move in this position
is actually to go the other way to move
the king to C5 and the whole point is
that after white plays King D3 the move
F2 F4 no longer comes with checks so now
it no longer dislodges Black's King from
the C5 square and that means that black
actually can win the waiting game and
actually induce one so how does this
work well once again I should start by
playing G5 you should try to choose
waiting moves that simultaneously
deprive your opponent of his or her
waiting moves right you shouldn't just
choose indiscriminately this prevents
white from pushing F4 so it's the most
strategic waiting move once the G3 G4
loses on the spot so uh White should
play the move F3 and now you follow the
same Prince principle the best move is
A3 to prevent white from pushing his a
pawn white plays G3 the waiting game
continues as it did with the King on E5
black pushes A6 very important not to
play A5 exhaust only one waiting move at
a time white plays F4 and this is where
this move no longer comes with checks
after gfgf black can simply continue the
waiting game with A5 and white is
already in zugswang no matter how white
pushes these Pawns
white creates a hole if white plays D5
he creates a hole on D5 and black wins
immediately pushing the king away from
D3 and infiltrating E4 and if white
pushes F5 then the hole on E5 is created
black secures the hole by playing F6 now
obviously the Breakthrough fails E5 F
takes E5 F6 King D6 and black easily
stops the pawn and if White
doubles back to D2 then black migrates
the king over to E5 King D6 now you
might say wait a second these are
corresponding squares on D3 and E5 why
it's not just going to step onto D3 and
allow zog's long but it doesn't matter
waiting moves allow you to hack the
concept of corresponding squares you can
actually step onto your corresponding
square if you have more waiting moves
than your opponent because after King D3
black exhausts his final waiting was
just a beautiful sequence and forces
White's King away from D3 this is and
white loses both of his remaining
kingside pawns and loses the game
so
just just an incredible sequence and and
every one of these moves has to be
played accurately if you play A5 here
then if we go down this line after F6 F5
you don't have that additional waiting
move here you exhaust your final laning
move and this is a draw because after
King E2 if you move up to C4 then you
allow the Breakthrough E5 and what
actually wins F takes C5 F6 the pawn is
Unstoppable so
after King D6 of course white just
circles around and if you step onto E5
once again you lose the game you don't
have that additional waiting move so
notice how raised or thin the margins
are between uh being winning and and
being losing there is often no middle
ground you have to be accurate so if we
rewind back to uh back to back to this
position uh White can also try to go the
other way Play and play the move A3 but
this loses in similar fashion black
advances the pawn to G4 continuing to
try to uh prevent white uh for making
waiting moves to G4 and after F3 here
you need to be accurate for one more
move G takes F3 relinquishes the win
after she takes F3 A6 F4 we get a very
similar scenario F6 F5 and black once
again has to exhaust his final waiting
move and we already know that this is a
draw so instead
um pause the video and see if you can
figure out an improvement what should
black do here if not g takes F3
thank you
well hopefully you were able to
determine that the correct move is in
fact G3 and of course this works because
it forces white to exhaust his waiting
moves first White has no choice but to
play F4 now we win in similar fashion A6
F5 F6 and actually
uh the the presence of these two
additional pawns does not matter at all
uh they don't change the nature of the
position King into King D6 and uh
blackwinds with a familiar procedure A5
and and this is one one other thing I
will add is that y can defend a little
bit more resiliently by moving the king
back to D2 first
um black plays King C4 and now I can set
a final Trap by playing F5 of course the
Trap is that black should not play F6
here E5 wins the game for white rather
black should drop the king back to C5
if E5 then the king moves into D5 and
this does not work that again the king
easily stops the pawn with King D6 and
then you go E5 and King E6
and of course uh if if white goes King
D3 then we've transposed back into uh
the position we already talked about
black plays F6 and zougs Wang is
imminent
so that ladies and gentlemen is the only
way that you can win this game you have
to go the counter-intuitive route you
have to go to C5 rather than E5 in order
to ensure that the move F4 does not come
with check and then you can keep your
protection of the D4 Pawn so this
example not only illustrates the power
of waiting moves and the way in which
waiting moves can really dominate the
game and dictate the result of the game
but it also shows us that you have to
look at each end game very concretely
and you cannot trust your gut instinct
all of the time when it comes to
deciding where to put your king you have
to try to appreciate the specifics of
the position if you want to squeeze uh
the most out of every game
okay so we have two exercises remaining
and one of them is a real doozy it's
this one but we're gonna get to this one
in a moment first we have our
penultimate exercise which comes from a
game uh between two very strong female
players kushlinsky and ostork now I will
mention that these last two examples
come from ahs.com article that I wrote
about seven years ago so if any of you
happened across that article and I've
seen these examples and I apologize but
I was I'm hopeful that in most cases uh
you know that article has fallen Into
Obscurity so hopefully you're seeing
these for the first time
so this example is just an awesome
illustration of several important
principles as well as the centrality of
corresponding squares and the importance
of understanding their implications so
it's white to move and and it should be
clear to you just from a couple of of uh
cursory moments of looking at this
example that white is playing for a win
white has the outside passer on P5 black
has a set of very vulnerable pawns on
the king side which white can try to
eliminate with his King with her King so
the first move is is very obvious this
is not a trap you start with a move King
D4 attacking the E4 pawn and everything
may seem at first sight to be super
straightforward black has no moves King
C7 King takes E4 and and black is you
know short by about a million miles why
it just eliminates uh the other the
other two pawns but as a keen student of
the end game you should notice pretty
quickly that black and use her Pawn
majority to break through on the king
side and make it as difficult as
possible for white to eliminate blacks
kingside pawns so it correctly plays the
move E3 this is the easy breakthrough F
takes E3 and F3
now this is a nasty turn of events for
white it may seem that black actually
promotes her Pawn but in fact she
doesn't white stops the pawn with King
D3 this is a a worthy construction to
remember yeah your E3 Pawn blocks the
king but if black pushes F2 then white
stops the pawn with King E2 so white is
not risking losing here but white is
risking
uh losing her winning chances because
now black takes the additional time to
play King C5
and well what's going on here well
clearly white needs to eliminate the F3
Pawn
uh in order to win the game but but how
how does this fight do that well why
does two ways to do that there is sort
of a more efficient method and then a
less efficient method but you should
remember that efficiency isn't always
the goal in Pawn end games and you
should remember that pushing unnecessary
pawns as as general and meaningless as
this is advice might seem can actually
help you gain a lot of points so the
efficient way to win back the F3 Pawn is
to push the epon forward creating a
pathway uh directly to the F3 Pawn this
is the direct flight but after King
takes B5 King E3 you should notice that
you have yielded this very important D4
square and now you allow Black's King to
shoulder you with King C4 King takes F3
and King D4 White's King is on the worst
possible spot White's very own pawns
blocked the white king from accessing
these important squares F4 is controlled
by the G5 Fawn and white has no choice
but to give up the four pawn and
therefore give up any winning chances
this is just a Draw Something Like D5
King takes D5 King E3 and the Kings just
start dancing around this is just a dead
drop so here we see a great illustration
of the fact that the fastest way to win
the F3 Pawn isn't actually the best way
and the best way is to leave this Pawn
on E3 so that it controls this very
important D4 square and doesn't allow
white skin to get shouldered the only
way move is King back to D2 you take the
circuitous the roundabout route but that
does not roll off the tongue kick takes
B5 King E1 black of course takes the
opportunity to move her King back to the
center if black tries to make a b line
for D3 then black is the one who gets
shouldered King D3 King takes F3
opposition and here opposition really is
very important because after black skin
moves away white of course just plays
King E4 and then King F5 and eliminates
the G5 Pawn so once again osterk takes
the most resilient continuation King C5
King F2 King to D5 King takes F3 King E5
and we have basically reached stage two
of the send game white has successfully
eliminated the F3 Pawn in successfully
avoided getting shouldered but now white
has to find a way to use her extra Pawn
to actually win the game now obviously
the move before is once again incredibly
premature it allows King D4 and again
the white king gets shouldered so it's
clear that white is just gonna have to
find some way to maneuver the king from
the King side let's say to the center to
D3 uh to a square that is going to allow
white to push the E Pawn without getting
shouldered
but it's impossible to do that properly
unless you have a keen understanding of
corresponding squares and unless you
have noticed that there is a key set of
corresponding squares in the center that
you have to avoid if you're white and
that set is the squares E2 and E4 I
remind you that uh in the event of a set
of corresponding squares you want to be
the last person you want to be the
second person to put your King on your
corresponding square if you put your
King on a corresponding Square first and
you don't have any waiting moves that's
the caveat uh then you are the one who
lands in zuzong and that is indeed the
case after King E2 King E4 black puts
her King in opposition and if white goes
to the left then black goes to the right
eliminating the G4 pawn and it's not
hard to establish that after E4 King F4
not only does white lose the pawn Race
White loses the game after King D4 G4
notice that white king is in the
checking zone of the black Jeep on black
promotes with Jaguar White's Pawn is
only on the seventh rank here black wins
the game
but that doesn't work and if you go to
the right side which is relatively
speaking the best continuation then you
have made no progress and after King D5
King F3 King E5 you're right back on
Square One you write back where you
started with
so as is the case in such situations the
key is to avoid stepping onto your
correspondence sorry you again have to
take the circuitous route you have to go
through F2 to E1 to D2 taking extreme
care to avoid stepping onto the E2 score
unless of course black is the first one
to step on her corresponding Square so
kashlinska correctly plays in this
position sorry let's rewind King F2
a historic circles around D5 and E5
neither side wants to put their King on
their corresponding Square first if King
E4 happens then white steps onto E2 now
black is the one in zuk zwang and this
basically reaches the position from the
game we're not going to talk about this
separately you'll see black plays King
D5 and King F2 to E1 if you don't
understand corresponding squares this
might seem like such a mysterious move
but the moment you get the concept right
uh you know this move starts to make
make perfect sense I really think that's
that the magical thing about learning
endgames is that these These Things
become totally demystified to you can
you one king E5 and King D2 black has no
choice but to continue toggling between
these two squares and now white claims
opposition with King D3
again black has to play King E5 and here
we have gained a Tempo in comparison to
the situation where
um
where where White's King is on D2 and
Black's King is on F3 now I can play E4
and with that additional Tempo white
actually wins the pawn race E4 King F4
this is stage three stage three as it
often is is a pawn race King D4 King
takes G4 E5 now you might say wait a
second after King F5 the pawns are going
to promote simultaneously but as was
indeed the case in our first example the
king is going to be on the file the
newly minted Queen is going to be on the
G file you know what that means that
means skewer land and that is the case
here oh stork played King G6 this loses
immediately to E6 uh G4 this is she sets
a final trap obviously not E7 King F7
and King E8 draws uh so instead you want
to make this additional move King D6 and
after G3 E7 white promotes with dragon
wins the game relatively more resilient
would have been G4 but here you know the
drill E6 G3 E7 G2 queen queen and the
final detail Queen F7 check forcing the
kick onto the G files we have seen so
many times and then Queen G6 followed by
Queen takes G1
so just a an incredible illustration of
of the the power of corresponding scores
just once again in this position white
has to avoid the E2 Square King E1 King
D2 and King T3 if black would have
played King E4 and then King E5 trying
to keep the opposition white uses
another concept that I outlined in the
previous video Pawn assisted opposition
white plays E4 and then steps into the
pawn assisted opposition where the pawn
controls the two squares on the fifth
rank forcing Black's King back and hear
the win is even more Elementary King D4
and then E5 and again Pawn assisted
opposition and then white the easiest
way to win is just to eliminate the G5
pawn and then use the two extra pawns uh
to win an elementary fashion uh so so
just a very very nice illustration of
these Concepts and that brings us to our
final exercise and this is really the
the cherry on top this is one of uh my
favorite examples to show because it's
it's so rich and and paradoxically
enough it comes from a five minute game
that I played uh eight years ago in 2014
on the internet chess club hopefully
that rings the bell at least for some
listeners this was the precursor to
chess.com this is where people used to
play and this is where I started my
online chess career so in this game I
have the white pieces against uh a
strong player I think he's probably
about I am strength Anonymous uh he went
by the username Franklin Pines
and uh we have a pawn end game I think
at this point both of us at about like
45 seconds left so not a lot of time to
calculate and and the first thing that
you should notice is that this is a pawn
race in the making white has a past C5
Pawn black as a Pawn on G3 and so really
before you get your bearings the first
thing you should do is just try to
calculate the move C6 and see what
happens if you just blindly push your
Pawn toward promotion so this move leads
to a queen end game where white is up a
punch C6 G2 C7 black promotes first but
white promotes with check giving white
the initiative
but this of course jumps the gun a
little bit we haven't talked about Queen
end games yet but in Queen end games the
material count is often superseded by uh
King activity and queen activity as as
is the case really in a lot of other
multi-piece end games and here because
of how active Black's King is because of
how weak white spawn are pawns are black
is able to handily to handily make the
draw so for example the best winning
attempts for white is to keep checking
in H3 trying to dislodge Black's King
from its contact with the E3 Pawn King
F2 Queen H4 check but the king just
toggles between F2 and F3
now if you take on F6 then black just
takes on E3 and this is easy so again
the most resilient attempt is Queen to
H5 trick forking the king in the D5 pawn
and forcing the king back to F2
might seem like after Queen takes D5
whites made a great deal of progress
because black can't take on E3 but what
black can do is give this incredibly
nasty check on B1 and whites King is
caught in occasion as another sneak
preview a concept that we will discuss
in our Queen end game videos is What's
called the Sundial and the Sundial is a
situation where the defending side just
pursues uh the attacking sides king and
queen in a skewer formation around the
board not allowing the king to escape uh
the roundabout so here black initiates
the Sundial look when they do you'll get
the concept really quickly King C5 Queen
A5 wherever the black the white king
steps the black king the black king The
Black Queen uh steps onto
the appropriate Square to keep the
skewer going White's King has to
maintain contact with the queen at all
times and so cannot Escape uh this
Circle of Death King C6 Queen ah King D6
queen dhek king E6 Queen G8 check notice
that the F6 spawn is controlling E5
that's kind of important
King D6 back to d8 and this is going to
be a repetition of moves just a really
really pretty uh instantiation of the
Sundown if white goes to C3 uh then then
black can throw in another check on C1
and then take the pawn on E3 and a white
is just unable to keep control of both
of these pawns these pawns are too weak
White's king is too exposed and the game
ends in a draw which is an unsuccessful
result for white who's trying to win
so a little bit of calculation reveals
that the first move C6 only ends in a
draw is there an alternative to C6 well
if you watch the pawn race video
carefully uh you will notice that you
will remember that one of the main
themes of Pawn races is using your king
to force your opponent's king onto an
inferior position before continuing the
race and that's precisely what white can
do here with the correct first move King
D3 to E2 so the point of course is that
G2 loses on the spot King F2 King H3 now
the very important move King Juan
getting behind the pawn and the game is
over white promotes the C Pawn so of
course black has to play King to H3 but
now the king is on the corner of the
board which greatly increases the chance
that you can force a queen trade and
that is indeed the case here now why
push a C6 there's no other choice G2 C7
G1 and C8 Queen and at first sight it
might seem like the game is over the
king and the queen again are on adjacent
files which means that if black stays on
the H file white can just give a check
on h8 and now give a check on G7 forcing
the queen trade but that's not the end
of the story here white has the easy
breakthrough with E4
and then D5 and white just promotes the
d-pawn and wins the game so this would
be a nice exercise if this was all that
there was to it but it wouldn't be the
final exercise of of this batch it would
be probably the first one and uh
hopefully you were able to notice and
Kudos if you were because this is not an
easy thing to conceptualize black can
actually get a more favorable version of
the pawn end game by initiating it
himself with Queen G4 check
and the point of course is that Black's
King is in a much closer proximity uh to
White's Pawn majority here the king is
on G4 rather than on G1
now
uh hopefully you're all stable to notice
that white can still break through right
in Black's face with the move E4 but
we'll get to that in a second if white
tries to sort of shoulder black skin out
of G4 with the move King F2 this is
going to fail because black is going to
Deep Freeze White's Pawn majority with
F5 and now white is never going to be
able to break through that just gives
black a protective passer and Black's
King is going to keep in again in close
proximity to to White's F Pawn so for
example in G2 King H4 and uh if white
plays King F3 black can very safely play
King HD because E4 allows F takes E4
check that is very important otherwise
white would play F5 uh and here of
course white actually uh White actually
loses the game so there's just no way
that white can circumvent this King E2
uh black as long as black stays close to
uh uh to the F Pawn with a move like
King G4 and white has made absolutely
zero progress King F3 King D3 King F2
and hear the very same principle if E4
black unfortunately takes back with
check so this attempt does not work
instead
E4 is the only winning attempt you break
through anyway and the key line is D
takes E4 D5 now black is able to stop
the pawn with King F5 but this is an
important formation to remember the F
Pawn controls E5 the d-pawn controls E6
so Black's King is totally locked in
zugsvong wide advances his King up to E3
this is in fact how the game continued
and black loses on the spot the black
king has to leave F5 and although
White's d-pawn doesn't quite promote D6
would be very premature because of King
F7 you can just pick up the E4 upon him
and you're just up a pawn now you simply
win by using the d-pawn as a decoy King
F5 and then King G6 and this is in fact
how the game ended King D6 F5 and my
opponent resigned uh because I'm just
going to take F6 on the next move or
play D6 first and then promote the F
Pawn but let's rewind to the position
after E4 if you look very carefully you
might notice that D take C4 isn't the
only move not only is it not the only
move it's far from the most resilient
move which is King takes F4 you
eliminate the F Bond first and after e
takes D5 you are still in time to stop
White's uh doubled past pawns with the
move King F5 if D6 then King E6 draws on
the spot and black strategy here is
going to be to wind the King around to
D6 using the F Pawn as a decoy so the
moment White's King reaches E4 defending
D5 black is going to play F5 dislodging
the king from E4 much like in the course
noise sax example so it may seem like
the game inevitably ends in a draw and
most students who I've shown this end
game to automatically consider King F3
to be White's only reasonable winning
attempt and once again this speaks to
the importance of resisting the urge
just to blindly trust what your
intuition is saying about the position
there's often going to be a natural move
but if you look at the position more
concretely you might often notice that
it's not necessarily the correct move so
King F3 draws without a fight black
plays King G6 white let's say plays King
F4 doesn't actually matter King F7 King
F5 King to E7 and that's it White's King
has reached a dead end Black's King is
going to step onto D6 on the next move
and much like I explained if white you
know here black and could do whatever
black and even play King F7 but the the
way to force the draw is King D6 King E4
and this key move F5 check again using
the outside passer to dislodge White's
King from the D5 Pawn King takes up five
King takes D5 and black eliminates the
final Pawn on the next move
so what's amazing about this is that the
only way to win is actually to take the
ridiculously counter-intuitive route you
have to go to the left side rather than
the right side and you have to abide by
perhaps the most important rule of Pawn
and pawn races which is that you have to
use your King as a weapon you have to
use your king to assist the progress of
your pawns especially in the situation
where your opponent's king is trying to
prevent the progress of your pawns and
the only way to assist the progress of
your pawns is to do it from the left
side of the board because that's the
only side that black is not controlling
and so the winning move is King E2 to D3
diagonal opposition but that doesn't
really matter after King G6 you don't go
to E4 that leads to exactly the same
scenario that we discussed you go to C4
and the point is that after whoops sorry
the point is that after let's see King
takes F4 he takes D5 King F5 King D3 G6
C4 black plays King F7 black tries to
get to D6 but he's not in time King to
C5 King E7 and white retress C6 just in
hot now if black starts to push his F
Bond black is not fast enough
King C7 F4
D6 King E6 D7 and white just promotes
first and wins in elementary fashion and
most importantly if in this position
black steps back to D eighth King is now
too passive it's too far away from
White's pawns notice the use of
opposition here restricting black skin
from the seventh Rank and winning the F1
while maintaining both of White's extra
pawns which is the only way to win this
position F5 King E5 black finally
reaches D6 but now he no longer has his
F Pawn so white is able to defend both
of these pawns at once and inducevang
and most importantly you should remember
that this is in fact a winning end game
because
without the D4 upon of course this is
this is a theoretical draw but with the
D4 upon white has that waiting move
which we exploit only when we need it in
this position we have that additional
waiting move forcing black sting out of
the shell and stepping onto E7 promoting
the d-pawn right so this is just a
worthy theoretical end game to remember
uh regardless of of everything else in
this position
so amazingly this strategy yields
Victory now I should point out the black
has a a much more resilient defensive
option instead of stubbornly going back
to F7 black should sense the danger and
start pushing his F Pawn as quickly as
possible F5 is the only way to prolong
the game
now if I place D6 this is again
premature black steps back to F7 and
obviously white does not make it to d8
in time so white has to burn a move on
King C5 continuing to use the king for
assistance
now if King F7 then white plays King C6
and we already talked about that so
black has to continue pushing his F
button F4 D6 F3 and the pawns promote
simultaneously but white has managed to
keep that extra D4 pawn and I did plug
this position into the end game table
base this is a win for white this is a
win for White and the way to start is
Queen ghx tossing the black king away to
the H file can't move to the f file
because of the skewer and after it moves
to the H file white pushes D5 again this
is way outside the scope of the video we
won't discuss this end game right now
but you can play around on table bases
yourself if you want to deepen your
understanding of it white is winning
though that you can take my word for I
did plug this position in and for the
sake of completeness I will point out
that black can also get a similar type
of end game by first playing King F7 and
now pushing F4 D6 F3 D7 F2 d8 F1 but
this is still a winning end game for
white and in short the reason this is
winning it might seem like a draw
because Black's King is very close to
the pawn but that's not actually a good
thing and the reason that's not a good
thing is because in many cases for
example it's a queen C1 black starts
checking you get a scenario like this
and already black is out of effective
checks because if Queen C3 check here
you can see why keeping the king in
close proximity to the pawn in such
positions can actually be a bad thing
it's because white can interpose with a
check forcing an obviously winning pawn
and game so both this and the end game
with the blacking on the H file are both
theoretically winning they're not easy
to convert but they are winning so you
know this this exercise is in fact sound
it's accurate to say that white can win
in the initial position but I definitely
had to mention this for the sake of
completeness still I don't think this
spoils the instructive value of White's
maneuver the the main pull of this
exercise is that
after King takes you four you have to
notice that this is the time for the
Breakthrough E4 and in this position you
have to take the counter-intuitive route
once again you don't go toward black
spawn you go away from black spawn but
toward your own pawns you have to
support their progress and you do so by
playing the move King D3 then King C4
King B5 and King C6 supporting the pawns
from the left side and in this way white
is able to force a win in this pawn and
game and in our final exercise
okay so once again you go King E2 you
force Black's King onto an inferior
Square then you initiate the pawn race
black gets a favorable version of the
Pawn in game but it doesn't stop the
Breakthrough if D takes E4 then black
sting is zugged after King takes f485
King F5 you have to find the correct
pathway for your Canyon that ladies and
gentlemen concludes our Whirlwind tour
of these five additional exercises
and once again I'm keeping my fingers
very much crossed that uh this recording
quality is going to be quite a bit
higher than my first two takes I'm just
going to put this one up whatever
whatever the quality is uh but I just
want to thank everybody once again for
your understanding it for the incredible
comments uh on on these end game videos
uh I know that the algorithm doesn't
always spit them out because of how long
they are but that doesn't mean I don't
appreciate uh the attentiveness and care
with which people watch them and the
incredibly wholesome comments that
people leave this community is awesome
and uh it's just a pleasure to make
these instructional videos for people
who are truly invested in their own
Improvement I'm going to continue doing
it and on this note we conclude our uh
tour of Pawn end games the next video is
going to be on Knight versus Pawn end
games and we're going to continue our
exploration of end games then but for
now hope you enjoyed the video folks
hope you enjoyed the exercises make sure
to review uh the solutions the written
out Solutions on uh in the description
uh you can click on either of the links
delete your studies and let me know what
you think alright folks I'll see you in
the next video goodbye
[Music]